despite the fact that old gen consoles
continue to march on we saw games this
year that simply couldn't have existed
on the playstation 4 the way they do on
the ps5 though many titles continue to
straddle the gap between old and new
there were experiences in 2021 that feel
like they're pushing gaming into the
future as they leverage the power of
sony's newest machine here's gamespot's
list of the 5 best playstation console
exclusives of 2021
if anything has shown off the graphical
power of the ps5 it's ratchet and clank
a game that feels like it couldn't have
existed in quite the same way before now
its central conceit is that reality has
broken with alternate dimensions
slamming into each other and mixing
together with chaotic often hilarious
abandon practically this means heroes
ratchet and clank find themselves
separated by dimensions and using new
abilities to jump through hulls in the
space-time continuum as they search for
a way to repair it the ps5's graphical
prowess and quick loading capabilities
make falling into and out of different
dimensions stunningly seamless which
makes it feel like you're exploring a
home multiverse of locations or
tunneling through wormholes to cross
impossible gaps or get the drop on
enemies there may not be a prettier game
on the market than ratchet and clank
rift apart which uses the ps5's hardware
and some brilliant art direction to
create something that looks like a
playable animated feature it's also
often a blast bringing that new hardware
to bear on developer insomniac's
long-running 3d platformer formula as
steve watts wrote in our review ratchet
and clank rift apart is flashy and
technically impressive without feeling
self-important it's just as silly sweet
and earnest as the ratchet and clank
series tends to be while the new
generation of hardware makes this entry
look and play better than ever a
heartfelt story fun characters rampant
humor and ludicrous weapons come
together to make ratchet and clank one
of the ps5's best and one of the few
games that truly feels next gen in 2021
the video game market has swollen with
games adapting the replayable ideas of
the roguelike genre elements such as
one-off visits to ever-shifting levels
that force you to find your equipment
along the way and hope for good luck
with returnal developer housemark used
its years of innovative thinking in
bullet hell games to make an indelible
mark on the world of roguelikes while
creating something that feels strange
and unique in the ps5 library returnal
is a roguelike bullet hell game adding
those elements to a third person shooter
but it's more than the ingredients of
that mixture thanks to fluid deft
controls and an incredible amount of
effort spent on presentation art
direction and sound design take you into
an incredibly alien sci-fi world where
returnal weaves its mystery how can a
place be so alien and yet so familiar
mike epstein wrote in our return review
returnal is constantly unsettling and
consistently challenging its mysterious
story and demanding action feel intense
urgent and fresh with returnal housemark
demonstrates its command of the arcade
arena finding ways to make elements of
top-down twin-stick shooters feel right
at home in a 3d game and demonstrating
that the right combination of elements
can make everything familiar feel
strange and new
listen we don't give out a lot of 10 out
of 10 review scores here at gamespot
death loop got one that should put it on
your radar but if you need more
convincing know that arcane studio's
immersive sim time loop game is in a
whole lot of ways a pinnacle of the
genre it's a game that drops you into a
world and forces you to get to know it
trusting that as you come to understand
the ins and outs the rules and
exceptions the players and the powers at
work you'll become this world's master
your ultimate goal is to play death loop
perfectly what's remarkable is that
arcane gives you the tools to do so and
trusts that eventually you'll succeed
it's not just that death loop is an
excellent experience in using firepower
and supernatural power to inflict your
will on hundreds of enemies the game is
defined by the depth invested in its
characters protagonist cult and
antagonist juliana and the many terrible
visionaries you're tasked with
eliminating its art direction imagines a
world that is perpetually on the
precipice of crumbling full of people
for whom death has no meaning and the
party never ends it's full of tiny
details and hilarious moments as systems
collide often resulting in characters
being annihilated tamor hussein wrote in
our death loop review
perhaps the most laudable part of death
loop is how it takes so many seemingly
disparate things and creates harmony
between them gameplay systems that feel
isolated become pieces of a bigger
puzzle and when you see how they
seamlessly connect together you realize
how special an achievement it really is
with chicory ps5 owners get something a
little different rather than wreaking
beautiful havoc as in death loop or
avoiding ever present death as in
returnal chicory is a game about adding
something of your own to the world
wielding a magical brush you can
literally paint the black and white 2d
landscapes around you both to solve
puzzles as you work through the game's
world of picnic and simply to restore a
little beauty and express originality as
you play painting is an essential
element of chicory but it's more than
just an opportunity to add a little
color to everything you see in whatever
way you see fit the game uses the
mechanics of art to explore deeply human
themes and feelings from the struggle to
create something great to the feeling
that you'll never live up to the
expectations of others or yourself
smart impactful writing finds emotion in
both its main story and the many
digressions you can take with the
characters you meet throughout the world
alessandro barbossa wrote in our review
chicory a colorful tale is a game about
self-exploration frequently presenting
earnest themes that can be challenging
to engage with given how relatable they
can feel but it's also an exercise in
confronting these insecurities and
barriers that prevent you from enjoying
what you put out into the world and
rediscovering its importance in the
process perhaps best of all chicory is a
game that can be played cooperatively
both locally and online making it a
touching game you can experience either
alone or together with someone else
nintendo just announced chicory will be
available on the switch so now nintendo
fans can get in on the art too
yes we wrote this before the nintendo
direct making chicory kind of a
trick choice but still it's great play
it
there's something comfortingly familiar
about kana bridge of spirits at least at
first the game draws inspiration from a
wide range of similar 3d action
platformers but don't be fooled by its
animated feature-like art style or by
the influences worn on its sleeve kane's
strength is in the way it combines great
ideas from throughout the genre together
to make a challenging game that feels
just as good to play as some of the
pinnacles of action adventure
deceptively difficult and mechanically
dense kane will put you through your
combat paces and hitting a stride in
linking together dodges parries critical
hits and melee beatdowns is an
incredibly satisfying experience as we
wrote in arcana bridge of spirits review
while kana bridge of spirits is full of
familiar feeling combat and exploration
its ability to find different ways to
look at those ideas makes for a
beautiful emotional and exciting journey
fun as it is to battle through cana
bridge's spirits many enemies and tough
bosses it's the design of the world that
defines it as protagonist kane you
venture through a destroyed village the
sight of a past calamity and help the
wayward spirits who once populated it to
find their way to peace that often means
uncovering their stories and helping
them to forgive themselves for their
failures in life while also battling
these struggling corrupted monsters
their pain has twisted them to become on
hand to help you are the rot a gaggle of
cute spirits who can distract enemies in
a fight or help you solve puzzles and
their constant companionship helps to
make the world feel alive and growing
kane is really a game about rebuilding
and restoring what was lost about moving
on and forgiving it's somber story
beautiful world and excellent
combination of mechanics both well-known
and fresh make it stand apart from other
similar games in 2021
so there you have it gamespot's top 5
playstation console exclusives of 2021.
we'll be revealing our top 5 xbox switch
and pc games as well so make sure you
hit that subscribe button so you can
catch up on the best games of the year
speaking of we also have a deep dive
into why death loop is our game of the
year so make sure you stick around for
that thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]